وقفه مع الحدث مع ازميله ارمتان اويت يا
مساء الخير اهلا رمضان رمضان بدايه ما هي
ابرز تحديات مؤتمر بغداد 2 الذي التئن في
الاردن دائما بمبادره الفرنسيه
ويجعل من دعم التنميه الاستقرار في العراق
في قلب دعم التنميه والاستقرار في المنطقه
لماذا لان من ابرز تحديات هو خلق ديناميه
جديده خلاقه وصيغه حوار رابح رابح بين
اللاعبين رئيسين اللذان يتواجهان على
الساحه العراقيه وهما ايران والمملكه
العربيه السعوديه
ومواجهتهم يعني تمتد ايضا الى ساحه اخرى
الى لبنان الى اليمن حيث ما زالت الازمات
السياسيه والاقتصاديه تعصف المنطقه
وبالتالي همم في الصدد هذه الصراعات
المفتوحه التي تسمم العلاقات نشروا الا ان
العراق بدا خلال من خلال هذه الديناميه
وابانا رئاسه الوزراء لرئيس الوزراء مصطفى
الكاظمي بدر الى خلق حوار على عده جلسات
بين ايران وبين المملكه العربيه السعوديه
للتقريب بين الخصمين وميزه الكاظم بانه
كان يمسك العصا من الوسط بين ايران وبين
السعوديه همم وهنا ورقه اخرى اراد مؤتمر
بغداد اثنان ان يلعبها هي ورقه عوده ايران
الى التفاوض الاوروبي حول النووي الايراني
ممثل السياسي الخارجيه للاتحاد الاوروبي
جوزيف بوزير الخارجيه الايراني قبل هذا
المؤتمر استبقته بالحديث عن ضروره التطبيع
العلاقات مع المملكه السعوديه التي وصفتها
بانها جار ايران في هذا السياق التي تشهد
فيه للشهر رابع على التوالي احتجاجات
داخليه هي التي يعني همم تراجعت في لحظه
الاخيره عن توقيع الاتفاق النووي مع دول
خمسه زائد واحد محتاجه الى الصيغه للخروج
همم يعني نافذه جديده من خلال هذا المؤتمر
لكن همم ما زالت ايران تملكه ورقه الضغط
الكبيره من خلال طبعا التغير الذي حدث في
العراق تحديدا وصول حكومه محمد شياع
السوداني الى السوده الحكم بعد اذن همم
فتره من الترنح السياسي شهدناها خلال
الاشهر الماضيه في العراق
لكن هذا المؤتمر الصحفي ثم الغاءه
جيله لساعه كامله قبل ان يتم الغائه هذا
لا هذا يعني ان لا نتائج لا اعلانات لا
جديد لا توافقات تمخضت عن هذا المؤتمر ولا
حتى صيغه الحد الادنى التي يمكن لرئيس
ماكرون مثلا ان يخرج بها وان يقول حققنا
هذا وذاك والرئيس ماكرون يحب اذا بدر الى
شيء ما ان يسوق لنتائجه هذا يعني بان
الامر يعني هذا المؤتمر كانت نتيجته صفر
وغياب لاعبان رئيسيان هما ولي العهد
السعودي محمد بن سلمان من جهه ورئيس
الامارات محمد بن زايد من جهه اخرى رساله
الى ايران رساله مفادها بان السعوديه
والامارات لا تثقانه في حكومه شائعه
السوداني الذي عين من طرف فرض من طرف
الاطار التنسيقي القريب من ايران بالاضافه
الى ان الغالبيه البرلمان في العراق
غالبيه تابعه لاو قريبه لايران وبالتالي
ايران ما زال تملكه الاوراق الاوراق
اللعبه العراق وهذا ما جعل الرئيس الفرنسي
يتحدث عن ضروره اخراج العراق من منطقه
النفوذ الخارجي هنا ايضا كلمه عن فشل
المبادره الفرنسيه بغداد اثنان ياتي تكمله
اذا فشل هذه
الدبلوماسيه الفرنسيه التي اراد الرئيس
ماكخان ان يعيدها الى المنطقه شتان بين
دبلوماسيه الفرنسيه في عهد جاكشي هاك في
الشرق الاوسط في سوريا في العراق في
المنطقه
والدبلوماسيه الفرنسيه اليوم التي حصلت
كثيرا همم يعني مقابل نفوذ الامريكي مقابل
النقود الصيني والروسي في المنطقه
وبالتالي همم باريس همم يعني خسرت الرهان
في هذه المبادره